[Musique]
s'appeler jérémy cohen il a été tabassé
en pleine rue le 17 février dernier
avant de se faire percuter par un
tramway à bobigny si cette histoire
avait été traité comme un banal fait
divers par les médias il s'agirait plus
précisément d'une agression antisémite
le jeune homme qui portait une kippa le
soir de l'agression était pris à partie
par un groupe de jeunes avant de
s'enfuir abassourdi d'être renversée sur
les réseaux sociaux eric zemmour a
dénoncé la banalisation de ce véritable
lynchage pourquoi aucun média ni aucun
politicien ni aucun membre du
gouvernement ne parle de la mort de
jérémy cohen tabassé par des racailles
ce soit ses proches témoigne en
exclusivité donc des pmp
je vais à marquer je voudrais remercier
d'ailleurs
benjamin petrover il 24mas qu ils ont dû
déplacer voilà votre intervention juste
pour que vous veniez ce chez nous ce
soir merci à gérald cohen le père de
jérémie d'être avec nous je vais
remercier franck serfaty l'avocat de la
famille et nos amis qui a suivi la
sphère noémie à louga qui a suivi la
faire et va nous raconter exactement ce
qui s'est passé
j'aimerais déjà d'ailleurs que ce soit
vous d'ailleurs qui m'ont raconté
qu'elle s'est passé parce qu'on avait
les vidéos circuler sur les réseaux
aujourd'hui ça a été condamné par toute
la classe politique
bien sûr marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon eric zemmour je sais pas si je
vois là après je sais pas si emmanuel
macron a réagi où le ministre de
l'intérieur voilà cette agression mais
racontez-nous ce qui s'est passé
exactement écoutez c'est un jeune juif
de 31 ans ce qu'on peut voir en tout cas
dans les vidéos ce qui est bien visible
ce qui fait donc prouvable par départ
des preuves parce que la caisse il ya
des questions qui demeurent bien sûr on
ne sait pas par exemple s'il portait sa
kippa à ce moment là là dessus on
raconter ce qui s'est passé parce que
pour que les gens qui nous rejoignent ce
soir comprenne ce qui s'est passé que
les côtés ces images horribles ce jeune
garçon on le voit se faire littéralement
tabassés roué de coups par une bande de
voyous il fait nuit et on le voit courir
pour essayer d'échapper à cette violence
il court et là il ya un tramway qui le
percute de plein fouet et on voit ces
images absolument atroce d'une violence
inouïe de ce corps qui gisent
derrière gillot c6 alors le problème
effectivement c'est qu'au début c'est
serré comme un accident c'est à dire que
les enquêteurs ont considéré que le
tramway elle avait accidentellement art
est d'ailleurs le chauffeur a été mis en
examen pour homicide involontaire
et c'est ensuite l'enquète de la famille
qui a permis de débusquer des vidéos
saisissantes où effectivement la
question qui se pose et qui semble même
bien réel on peut y répondre c'est qu'il
aurait été agressé et tabassé et donc
que sa mort serait due au fait qu'il
portait une kippa et donc qu'il est juif
donc on serait sur un meurtre antisémite
alors maître fonde serfaty que sait-on
précisément défi aujourd'hui alors
objectivement nous avons certains
éléments tangibles ce jeune garçon
circulait à bobigny de façon très
paisible il n'est pas un voyou il n'est
pas connu des services de police et
encore moins de la justice et puis aux
alentours de 20 heures 25 je parle sous
le contrôle du papa il est pris à partie
en fouiller tout seul tout seul y
circulent encore une fois paisiblement
et il entoure est encerclé par une bande
qu'on a appelée devoyon en tout cas
aujourd'hui
en respectant le secret de l'enquète
fils secret de l'instruction puisqu'une
une information judiciaire a été ouverte
voici 48 heures il est entouré par
quinze ou seize individus qui sont
rejoints par un individu est d'ailleurs
on le voit dans la vidéo litigieuse qui
circulent de façon virale depuis ce
matin 10 10 heures du matin ce groupe
est rejoint par un individu le plus
véhément qui assène toute une série de
coups d'une violence extrême donc on est
à 25 a encore une fois jérémy cohen
décédé vous venez de lui rappeler arrive
à s'échapper cours pour fuir pour
échapper à ses agresseurs et percute une
rame de tram ou et tramway t1 à bobigny
et meurt pratiquement quelques heures
après alors pour répondre à une question
qui sera peut-être opposés sur le
caractère antisémite à ce jour l'acte
antisémite la circonstance aggravante
d'antisémitisme n'est pas prouvée
d'accord par contre bien évidemment une
information a été ouverte vendredi donc
il ya 48 heures les son le temps de la
justice le temps judiciaire et accordons
au magistrat instructeur
un temps raisonnable pour établir
premièrement qui était présent pour
quelles raisons jérémy cohen a été
littéralement lynché est ce que cette
circonstance aggravante et réunis nous
le dirons après en tout cas moi avocat
de la famille je ne viens pas vous dire
ce soir que ce crime est antisémite mais
je n'exclus pas loin s'en faut cette
possibilité aggravante sachant que ces
violences ayant directement entraîné la
mort 1 constitue juridiquement une
infraction criminelle et non pas
délictuelle se sont pas des violences
volontaires sont des violences ayant
directement et immédiatement entraîné la
mort car chacun l'a compris d'ailleurs
on le voit dans cette vidéo jérémy est
tout simplement fracassé un roué de
coups il s'échappe pour justement
s'enfuir de cette violence qui a priori
en tout cas ce soir nous apparaît
gratuite et ce n'est que parce jeps et
de chute si le heurte le métro avec
cette chute mortelle puisqu'il en est
mort donc il ya une relation de cause à
effet avec bien évidemment une
qualification criminelle en tout cas
c'est ce qui nous apparaît aujourd'hui
et c'est ce que je défendrai alors là
demain auprès du magistrat instructeur m
jean qu'ils ayez un instant qu'il était
retenu au départ un accident de la
circulation
vous nous confirmer ça alors je vous
confirme et le papa qui a mené son
enquête avait que deux de ses garçons de
deux fils c'est effectivement pourra
vous expliquer qu'il ya eu trois temps
auquel je n'étais pas présent ayant été
mandaté jeudi dernier par la famille
cohen effectivement une plainte et une
intervention auprès des services de
police le 17 février 2022 c'est à dire
le land mains de cette mort je n'ai pas
utilisé le terme crime qui a une
connotation ou meurtre ou assassinat
c'est une connotation juridique en tout
cas ce soir on parle de morts
la police ne semble pas prendre cette
affaire avec la cruauté que nous la
connaissons ce soir deuxième étape
toujours au stade de ce qu'on appelle l'
enquête préliminaire avec des
interventions répétées de la part de la
famille cohen qui voulait comprendre
bien sûr et qui ne pouvait pas se
satisfaire de cette position votre fils
est mort accidentellement
on ne peut rien vous dire on classe
affaires donc il a un appel à témoin de
la part d'un des garçons de gérald cohen
qui n'est pas fructueux puisque très
rapidement courant février 2022 la mort
datant du 16 février dans les jours
suivants la famille colette un certain
nombre d'éléments tangibles dont la
vidéo mais aussi corroboré par des
témoignages puisque la société civile a
réagi un certain nombre de personnes
présentes sur la scène du crime
le 16 février s'est manifesté auprès des
enfants cohen et la famille a pu
récupérer un certain nombre d'éléments
tangibles qui ont été portées fin
février à la connaissance de la police
d'où une deuxième étape de la part de la
justice et notamment du ministère public
du procureur la république de bobigny
avec une troisième étape que j'ai cités
à titre introductif la désignation par
le procureur la république vendredi
dernier d'un juge d'instruction qu'il a
pour le coup à l'obligation de ne pas la
loi d'enquêté enquêter à charge ou à
décharge
mais on a aujourd'hui un magistrat du
siège un juge d'instruction qui devra
essayer à tout le moins avec les
éléments qui sont présents ce soir et
ceux qui arriveront ce qui
interviendront dans les semaines à venir
en tout cas nous l'espérons de mener une
enquête pour faire justice et pouvoir un
savoir réellement ce qui s'est passé
monsieur cohen merci d'être avec nous ce
soir oui merci au nom vallongue le
recevoir je vois là les réactions là sur
les réseaux beaucoup de gens disent
qu'ils sont voilà ils sont brisés par
par cette affaire
vous vous avez voulu savoir la vérité
tout de suite
c'est pas ça c'est que si vous voulez
après l annonce de sa mort le lendemain
matin
mon épouse et moi on a été au
commissariat et on nous a posé vivent
deux amis chacun dans un bureau nous a
posé différentes questions classiques
pour les enquêteurs et on comprenait pas
trop déjà pourquoi on ne peut certes en
question mais bon on a fait ce qu'on
nous a demandé et après on nous mêmes on
a posé la question qu'est ce qui s'est
passé et là on nous a dit qu'il
semblerait qu il aurait été poursuivi et
qu'il aurait couru à travers des
voitures les qu'il aurait une kippa
manche
donc et on nous a demandé est-ce qu'il
avait ça qui passionné à ce moment là
alors qu'on n'était pas là on comprenait
rien ce qu'on me disait de plus je
pensais à mon fils que j'avais vu hier
on était toute la nuit avec lui
on a fait les les prières nécessaire
quand il ya un décès comme ça
et on était avec lui donc à l'hôpital
ma femme et ma fille est donc après on
est on est rentré à la maison comprenait
pas donc on a essayé de préparer les
obsèques et à ce moment là il y a
on nous a dit qu'ils gardaient le corps
parce qu'il voulait faire des
prélèvements toxicologiques mais qui
autorise quant à nos principes ce qu'ils
connaissaient par le fait que l'hôpital
comme jérémy décès
l'accident vers 20h10 et que après ils
l'ont réanimé et
l'hôpital qui nous a appelé la veille le
fait que vous appelez le 17 février à
une heure du matin le médecin
réanimateur
[Musique]
sur sa canne et si l'on me qu'il est
mort vers minuit et demi et aux appelés
vers une heure du matin
donc à partir de ce moment là bas
et que après qu'on est au commissariat
on comprenait pas trop ce qui se passait
et mes enfants et qu'on peut on raconter
ce qui s'est passé ils comprenaient plus
donc à partir de là ils ont fait des
flyers quand vous voyez ils ont fait ça
ça met un peu plus grands ils ont fait
ça sur l'imprimante à la maison et ils
on a malgré le chagrin malgré la
souffrance malgré leur je voulais savoir
la vérité voilà ils ont distribué à tout
le monde là-bas ils ont mis des affiches
et puis des gens très aimable de toutes
sortes qui nous ont aidés
ils ont porté des témoignages jour dix
classes et moi j'étais au courant de
rien donc ça se passe et comment vous
avez appris la mort de votre fils bas à
l'accident des fruits et ben on était à
la maison ce qui est mercredi 16 février
moi je me suis réveillée avant que le
téléphone sonne comme ça vers une heure
du matin et deux minutes après le
téléphone a sonné je me souviens j'étais
angoissé je sais pas ce qui se passait
et il ya un médecin qui nous a dit que
c'est votre fils ils ont été très graves
g10 qui quoi qu'on en dise c'est bien
votre fils jérôme cohen j'ai dit oui et
m'ont dit c'est très très grave et après
il m'a dit 'il aimant et après je me
suis évanoui et c'est ma femme qui a
pris le téléphone le relais elle mais
elle s'est occupée de moi et après on
est parti
donc à l'hôpital on nous a mis dans une
grande salle on nous a présenté le tout
l'équipe médicale on nous a dit que le
corps a énormément souffert qu'eux ils
ont passé au scanner qu'enfin de choses
comme ça et puis après on nous aviez est
ce que vous voulez le voir
zadi une jambe jeudi d'un coup aussi
après qu'il ait passé sous le tramway et
on va dire ce que vous voulez voir on a
dit oui et quand on a été le voir nous a
dit qu'il n'avait pas trop de fractures
qu'il avait beau j'ai vu j'ai rien on
dirait qu'il dort mais il avait un très
gros pansement au niveau
pariétal droit ou
au niveau de leurs beats moi j'ai fait
toutes les prières ma faim mais c'est
cool et ma fille s'est retournée
personne a voulu voilà
bon après on a une petite on n'était pas
d'accord si moi je voulais rester avec
le corps de mon fils et ma femme et ma
fille m'ont ramené à la maison quasiment
puis à prendre ainsi préparer les
obsèques et puis comme ils ont gardé le
corps donc on a attendu puis mercredi
suivant comment au début on vous avait
juste dit qu'il était passé sous le tram
enfin
vous avez ça le médecin d'accord et on
nous a dit qu'on était au commissariat
on nous a dit c'est un accident n'ont
aucune sérieuse et des pâquis corps
entre les voitures qui semblait pas
suivi
et que après le drame il avait eu des
problèmes à bobigny avant ou pas du tout
non mon fils mon fils était quelqu'un de
brillant il avait eu un bac s il a eut
fait trois années de mathématiques et
d'informatique appliquée à jussieu et
après il a été un peu déprimé fatigué il
a été il a pris d'un traitement qu'il
fallait il a il est heureux de vivre il
était bien et il aimait bien des fois le
bal matin des fois ça arrive et il
aimait bien l'informatique et les jeux
et l'après midi il est allé
pour se détendre ou faire des décors
soient les cours je sais pas sincèrement
mais bon il est mort hélas qui prime et
bien marché oui portait la kippa
généralement
toujours je veux pas mourir parce qu'il
n'a pas les mêmes réactions nous mais
lui la kippa pour lui c'était pas quand
quelqu'un qui porte la kippa pour des
raisons religieuses lui ça nous fait
plaisir d'apporter il apporte
c'est pas quelqu'un qui la mettrait pour
des raisons de religion c'est gagner
mais parce que sa satisfaction
personnelle c'est compliqué à dire sur
comme quelqu'un qui a envie de mettre un
bonnet ou un truc mais voilà il avait un
handicap non visible c'était quoi c'est
un handicap léger c'est à dire que
jérémie a une sorte de il a dû il avait
du mal des fois ce concentré il marchait
lentement c'est quelqu'un qui trouve
très doux qui aimait rendre service aux
autres mais qui arrivé un truc à faire
ils étaient là pour aider du travail et
donner tout assesseurs il avait mon
coeur il ne restait comme ça mais il
était lent et envoyé qui enfin quelqu'un
qui
de loin on voit qu'il a des réactions il
était lors quoi voilà et donc c'est déjà
arrivé que les gens qui vont quitter
après 40 ans du cap légers ils pouvaient
éventuellement comme des gens ils ne me
sens pas dans des handicapés ou à des
gens faibles noémie à yucca vous êtes
journaliste y 24 nous aujourd'hui
c'est quoi la faire écouter ce qu'on
sait c'est surtout on doit déterminer le
caractère antisémite mais puisqu'il
n'est pas exclue permettez moi de parler
de ce problème qui existe en france qui
est qui est un réel problème
l'antisémitisme ça ça fait aussi que des
juifs quittent leur village écrit un
livre sur la ville de sarcelles qui a
été le royaume des juifs à un moment
donné où il ya une très grande
communauté juive et elle s'est vidée en
partie parce que certains se sont
embourgeoisés mais aussi parce que il y
à ce problème de l'antisémitisme qui
sévit aujourd'hui dans certains
quartiers et qui pousse certains juifs a
quitté la france à quitter leur
territoire à souffrir il ya des
agressions antisémites tous les jours en
france et on n'en parle pas assez et
c'est un vrai problème et donc si ce
caractère n'est pas exclue permettez moi
aujourd'hui de poser cette question sur
la table et des deux est de porter la
voix aussi de tous ces juifs qui ont
honte d'être ville qui ont peur d'être
juif qui met une casquette sur leur tee
pas parce qu'ils ne ils ont peur d'être
agressés parce qu'on va voir qu'ils sont
juifs ou qu'ils rangent leurs lors leur
étoile de david et qui la range dans
l'eure dans leur chemise parce qu'ils
ont peur qu'on la voit et toutes ces
petites frayeurs si vous voulez elle
montre le problème aujourd'hui qui est
que de fait d'être juif en france
aujourd'hui c'est difficile et surtout
dans certains quartiers comme on dit
alors oui le m avec votre permission
bien évidemment à ce que je disais tout
à l'heure c'est que je ne peux pas
aujourd'hui d'un point de vue juridique
morice avocat je ne suis pas philosophe
journaliste ou sociologues je me base
par rapport à derek ne sont pas morale
qui sont purement juridique par contre
bien évidemment je suis avocat d'une
association dont la mission fondamentale
depuis 20 ans le bnvca et de lutter
contre l'antisémitisme et nous avons des
actions judiciaires devant les
juridictions à la fois délictuels et
criminel régulièrement pratiquement tous
les jours pour autant aujourd'hui on ne
doit pas et vous avez raison exclure le
paramètre antisémite mais on n'a pas le
droit non plus d'aller près tendent à
une infraction criminelle à caractère
antisémite ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya eu ces violences que nous
voyons au travers de cette vidéo alors
je fais partie de ceux qui ont tendance
à se méfier de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui une métiers dits
médiatisation outrancière
j'ai tendance aussi à me méfier de cette
vérité qui n'en est pas une au travers
des réseaux moi ce qui m'importe c'est
la vérité judiciaire
pour autant cette vidéo elle est là et
elle doit en tout cas nous l'espérons
dans l'intérêt de la famille permettre à
la justice d'avancer parce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui assurément un début de
preuve par contre et ne permettez moi
aussi ce sera le mode est en tout cas
pour moi de rappeler que la classe
politique et on ne peut pas vouloir tout
et son contraire a exprimé un
écoeurement par rapport à cette violence
est bien évidemment si les hommes et
femmes politiques étaient restés
insensibles la famille cohen l'aurait
mal pris mais ce qu'on ne veut pas ce
soir et demain c'est qu'il est né
récupération partisane mais tour à
l'orée de deux grandes élections
l'élection présidentielle dimanche
prochain qui sera suivi des élections et
c'est une législative
un homme politique est un être humain
qui peut bien évidemment face à cette
vidéo est aujourd'hui on n'a rien
d'autre exprimer ce que j'ai appelé un
sentiment d'écoeurement bien sûr par
contre on ne veut pas et là je parle en
qualité de représentant de la famille
comme un coing tilliet une récupération
de quelque nature que ce soit et encore
moins politique dans le contexte actuel
girard
monsieur cohen aujourd'hui
c'est ça s'est passé il ya un mois et
demi
vous vous sentez on comprend
complètement abattu vous n'arrivez pas à
passer aux balles le fait moi je j'avais
du mal à m'accrocher
depuis décès de mon fils j'étais
parti un peu avec lui enfin c'est ce que
je voulais mais
là en remettant la vidéo ça m'a un peu
pour vous pour des gens c'est des vidéos
pour d'autres c'est de la violence
pour moi c'est
mon fils donc je ça m'a fait souffrir
beaucoup donc j'ai replongé un peu en
arrière comme si c'était hier à quoi
donc surtout que jérémy était très doux
quand il était gentil et j'ai moins tant
que père je réduis être là pour le
protéger j'ai pas pu voilà et
donc voilà je skie a été dure depuis le
départ c'est que nous de voir mes
enfants comme ça ils ont vu faire les
flyers ils ont distribué tout après ils
ont dû se battre pour pouvoir essayer de
porter plainte correctement après ils
ont dû en malgré qu'on a mené tous les
bons éléments heureusement qu'ils ont
fait mais oui mais on a quasiment
honnête ans étaient seules deux
pour faire tout ça c'est à dire on s'est
retrouvés
on comprenait pas ce qui nous arrive est
parce que nous on a confiance en la
justice on a confiance en tout ça et on
affaire à la police avant ou à la
justice à mon âge n'ont jamais
nécessaire n'a jamais eu de problème
vous pouvez bien sûr dans les canapés
connais des gens simples on a élevé tous
nos enfants ils ont fait leurs études en
âge et mon problème tous mes enfants ils
ont tous eu le baccalauréat ils font
tous des études
soro de leurs études gérer mieux aussi
voyez c'était pareil sauf que jérémy sûr
l'ensemble de mes enfants il a il avait
un petit handicap léger quoi voilà est
ce qu'on n'a pas compris c'est pourquoi
nous
pourquoi nous on devait amener les
preuves quoi pourquoi nous on devait
aller enquêter pourquoi nous on devait
aller
vous faire tout ça ça ne vous avez un
peu de temps de faire votre deuil de
vente la peine puisque ou non parce que
moi je croyais au départ parce que les
enfants il m'avait tout cacher parce que
j'étais dans un état
assez
dramatique malgré les médecins et les
médicaments elle est cachée que j'avais
ils ont tout lâché pour moi enfin eux
mêmes ils savaient pas au départ il aura
fallu des avoirs d'avoir les preuves
aussi devant le donc ont dépensé 500
tramways mais même avec l'accent de
tramo on n'a pas compris
parce que gabriel a dû transférer aussi
tout ça à l'igpn votre niveau parce que
on voyait que de shooter on s'en sortait
pas donc il a transféré sa à l'igpn un
peu ce qu'on appelle la police des
polices et après il a été porté plainte
parce que on voyait que l'on pouvait pas
nice avancer ni s'en sortir je connais
aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous aimeriez qui se passe bas que
simplement ils attrapent ces gens là
parce que on a vu souvent moi je ne
connais pas trop mais on a vu souvent
qu'il ya des gens qui font ça y est il
ya quelqu'un que café du sport qui
maillent d'une chose je sais pas si
c'est vraiment fou il mène les fouilles
des gens ils ont la rage comme ça il
frappe frappe sans savoir pourquoi après
il peut plus arrêter donc mais si ces
gens là ils l'ont fait une fois et ça va
leur faire sur n'importe qui même au
delà de ça c'est une année this sais pas
si on peut pas on espère que l' enquête
avance sans en dévoiler plus m es ce que
l'enquêté avancé ce qu'on a déjà
identifié les alors si vous voulez c'est
ce que je disais à titre liminaire une
phase de latence totalement incomprise
de la part de la famille koh m mais la
déclinaison maintenant alors la vidéo on
l'a déjà depuis un mois donc ses
aventures on avance on l'a depuis un
mois je pense que c'est cette fameuse
vidéo au devenu viral depuis ce matin et
a permis d'enclencher une réaction plus
vive plus dynamiques du parquet du
procureur de la république et encore une
fois pour répondre précisément à votre
question la désignation vendredi d'un
juge qui a l'obligation d'enquêter qu'on
appelle un juge d'instruction donc lui
enquête a démarré avec cette ordonnance
de désignation qui va constituer le
point de départ d'une information d'une
enquête en termes simples mais qui peut
durer un an deux donc je rejoins ce que
disait mon client vous avez bien compris
que la famille cohen elle ne jette aucun
disque reding sur ni sur la justice mais
sont attendus six semaines ni sur la
police qui sembleraient avoir eu un
positionnement qui n'est pas conforme
aujourd'hui à ce qu'il aurait dû être le
17 février ni même sur vous les médias
parce que j'entendais dire voici
quelques dizaines de minutes où j'ai lu
au travers des réseaux les journalistes
n'en parle pas mais je pense que les
journalistes n'ont pas parlé parce que
l'information n'avait pas circulé
je les suis moi moi j'ai su grâce à une
amie qui habite à bobigny tellement
parlé du flyer qui tournait tout ça donc
j'ai demandé à mes équipes ce week-end
de commencer à enquêter mais c'est
vraiment ces voix-là cgg de la famille
encore à bobigny la séquence il est le
pour être totalement honnête parce que
vous avez bien compris qu'on est dans
une dynamique de transparence totale à
l'actionnaire la famille cohen
au tout départ et je crois que c'est le
parisien sans trahir au canon disait
mort au renversé par un tramway y attend
mais malheureusement à paris dans les
grandes villes des morts renversé par
des tramways vous en avez beaucoup il a
fallu l'anc est bien sûr de les frères
coen il a eu cette fameuse vidéo
conjuguées à des attestations 1 la vidéo
n'est pas le seul élément probant pour
qu'on comprenne que ce n'était pas une
mort accidentelle mais que le dessin de
jérémy cohen était la suite logique
directe et immédiate d'une agression
sauvage qui tombent sous le coup de la
loi pénale ercis